[Music]
yeah it looks like both players ready
hikaru representing tsm is esports
oregon
where off here your car gets the white
pieces starts the e4 we're getting a
sicilian
that actually surprised me for a bullet
game yep and
wow look at this i think that uh this
position already speaks to
king side pressure and uh looking at the
cam from faroush it almost looks like
he's playing on his phone oh yeah he's
looking down there
he's trying to figure out what's going
on he should look at his king side
because there's a bishop on d3 staring
at the h7 pawn
and black has to go for knight a5 at
some point but instead he throws an h6
this is actually going to be a problem
from queen d3
when you play g60 h61 yeah you're you're
calling it this
is very unpleasant queen d3 aiming at h7
he played f5 to deal with that but it
doesn't really deal with it rook f5 is
such a shaky defense
and you know what doesn't deal with this
look at the clock by the way hikaru has
48 seconds he's up
20 full seconds against ferruja and for
just king is being hunted
yeah not acceptable and look at this i
mean f4
all this but look at the time i feel
like he actually is playing on his phone
no way that that would be pretty absurd
his bishop's getting trapped so
uh that's not we need seven yeah just
upbeat full rook if i'm molly raza
i think i've had enough in game one i'm
moving on to game two yeah
so weird so weird this is not a good
start
excuse me not a good start for ali raza
at all although
hikaru is making this a bit more
complicated than probably he needed to
that king on g1
there's some air in front of it and
queen g4 check queen h3 now you can take
on b3 and you take the bishop at the end
it's the time though he's down 20
seconds it's just
never going to be enough yeah that car
very smartly brings that queen back to
d3 how many pounds does he have by the
way it's five pawns
he has enough and black might even be
worse anymore
yeah he's just he has to resign because
of the time but uh honestly i
i probably called that one early based
on the time alone
but even based on the position i think i
called it too early that was really
impressive that
ali reza made a game out of that but
alerissa has a clear
blueprint of what not to do you cannot
be down 20 seconds in the clock
to the car and look at a car trading
queens here you have to because
if you move the knight back you lose d4
b2 if you don't move the night back
you're gonna lose your knight
and we see the trade here and king to d2
play against this french bishop just try
to clog the d4 square
he's gonna kick that knight out and back
to c6 we go and you cannot
easily go bishop to b7 you better bishop
d7 to get out of the pin
that's right but c takes d4 i think you
can get away with that for now he said
he trades the bishops that's the bad
french bishop you might as well get rid
of it
and oh pawn sacrifice that move
that knight on c4 is going to be strong
and
he's allowing knight b2 and just running
his king away is knight e193 the idea
what rook takes three what oh my gosh
he's just blown a piece
no this is something there's something
funny going on with ali reza right now i
i think he's somehow he seems like he's
totally off like slower not as
tactically alert he needs to
regroup and get back in this match asap
with the next game so remind
everybody of what you were saying about
wearing chess bra apparel
and better chess well he's leaning down
so far robert you can't see the shirt
that's true that's true sit up straight
stop playing on your phone alyreza let's
let's get some energy in here
do we actually have any confirmation
that he's playing on his computer i mean
we have the fair play cams and
everything so
it does look like he is playing on his
phone the way he's angled this doesn't
look good for his back so
uh you know if any chiropractors are out
there it's okay he's young he'll be all
right but bishop takes h6 is that threat
by the way so watch out for bishop
h6 the bishop is on e7 but i'm looking
for that if the bishop ever leaves the
e7 square
mm-hmm queen b2 you're also looking for
that move uh trying to beat bishop h7
check right and just maneuvering by
hikari he's up 10 seconds
just i mean seriously like every game
he's up 10 seconds like it's no
but this is the it's unacceptable speed
i i
don't know why he's he's so slow a
little bit nervous i'm
i'm not sure i've never seen ali reza
really play this way
and we're being told he's playing on his
laptop rather than on his monitor and
well maybe he should go back to the
monitor because
this is not working out from ikaro jumps
to a two-nothing lead and very
impressive play by ikaro
once again in this game look at all the
control over the position
black has no active play and that causes
you to burn time if you're already
it definitely does oh look at these
bishops just one bishop
and then two bishops c4 h4 and all of a
sudden he's winning material on that
head
bob from hikaru nakamura yeah he should
be feeling it right now
he's oh i i'm like g5 you just take it
but the rook on a5 came to the rescue
so maybe the head bob is a little bit
too soon but once again
the clock is telling the story here the
clock speaks volumes obviously he needed
to take that rook before recapturing on
d4
a little bit he just blunted the piece
and queen of such a great move we have
two oh they were talking too the rook's
hanging
oh and he resigned wow i don't know if i
would have resigned there because
alvarez only had nine seconds remaining
but that is
a sign of respect like whoa i i'm i
can't get ahead of myself here
oliveriza fights back in that game and
he cuts the deficit in half
and now he has chances once again
amazing how if he lost we would have
thought oh this match might be over
right now he's right back in this thing
completely and
i mean i've never seen a head bob go so
wrong oh oh my gosh
knight d5 and the e6 yeah that's a piece
this is gonna be like a a masterpiece if
this works out
at ef7 king f7 there's i don't see a
follow-up
well it's going to be a masterpiece for
either player if this works out because
if he card defends this that's also very
impressive
yeah it looked like a good sacrifice at
first but hikaru's king on f7 i'm sorry
i cut you off there but i
i saw the piece sacrifice and it was
exciting and
honestly it looks like your car is going
to put a knight f5 and there goes your
attack
and it's crazy how it just went from
something to nothing like it now it's
just there's no threats at all
yeah there probably was something there
but you needed pinpoint accuracy
and all there is it just didn't oh my
gosh yeah
that's angry hikaru yup that's that's
bounced back hikaru
yeah that really is and alvarez needed
that game you know he would have tied up
the match
all the momentum would have swung his
way and now we're getting one of the
nerdiski tank playbook we saw this
we have and i feel like an expert on
this line already especially for bullet
um he's going bishop back to c2 and how
many times have we seen that
you know queen d3 idea of being
threatened in this match
okay we have a rook trade g5 play that
does expose the black king
but already's claim is that you don't
have pieces to go and attack me with and
that knight on the c5 is really strong
yeah rookie two though good counter play
a4 by white when he gets the moment and
the moments now he says attacks that
bishop which doesn't have a lot of
places to go
so goes bishop c4 if that bishop moves
the b-2 pawn okay was hanging but that's
where the knight took
and i like all there is to control this
position knight come to e4
this looks like black has all the
activity
yeah i was even thinking maybe queen e4
uh was possible to trade queens and then
get the knight in for the same idea
well here comes c5 drops the d5 pawn
wait rookie one
pins everywhere who's pinning who here
robert
it looks like white is pinning black
because that 94 is actually under attack
the 93 is protected
and queen these what are moves of play
probably the only move to play and
what's the count two extra pawns for
white so hey car
objectively doing very well here night
oh rook c1 knight f1 but
yep god i don't even know if that worked
he has ideas there
look at this game by ali reza i feel
like he's been so tricky right now
[Music]
because he was expecting brook d7 so he
played a6 and a car
smartly but rook d6 in anticipation of
that move
but look at the clock by the way ali
raza is getting close here rook takes b6
and work a6
yeah there's a six okay it was rookie
eight
but this probably is objectively lost
for
black but practically speaking in a time
scream but you can maybe remember do you
think he's about to
grab the a7 pawn at the right moment
yeah we i think a car is waiting for
that
he watched that match for sure yesterday
and but you can't check now that's a oh
wait what did the car just do
he moved his rope he's gonna get flagged
here oh
my gosh he tricked him and and ollie was
trying to win on the clock he's trying
to dirty flagging but he might get
flagged he might get flagged
oh the car wins hikaru wins
what a game that was and we see just
the disbelief on hikaru's face that he
flagged ali razor from that
and on the race that leads further into
the laptop
and he is down three points today
nakamura
i wouldn't be surprised if everyone
watching at home if ali reza's head just
shows up in your living room he's about
to enter that computer screen
wow i can't believe that robert that was
insane i thought that with that dirty
move rook a1
he had it in the bank it seemed to be
the case and i'm sure that hikar felt
the same way then all of a sudden he
turns it around
and this is the exact type of system
that gave others of trouble against
glass of artemia
i said it probably more the same for me
carl he loves these types of setups
and the problem for oh well not anymore
e6 coming your way soon
you're not loving this setup that's for
sure no i liked it before when it was
closed now that it's open i hate it but
alireza said you know it's not his type
of game he wants the tactical play
and e6 doesn't quite work because the
queen will take an e6 but
uh that was barely an escape there by
icaru
100 uh still a great position for ali
rezai he's obviously got the bishop pair
better pawn structure bishop on g7 not
even doing anything and look at this
knight e4 yeah he gives it the bishop
pair to give black the worst pawn
structure and as you're pointing out the
bishop on g7
is kind of useless so the pawn chain
from b2 to e5 connect four
also wins in chess and this looks great
for all theresa
yeah take that pawn still though
hikaru's gonna establish a knight on d5
which is uh tricky and
really the bishop on g7 which is the
issue okay so he's just trying to go
after this white king actually
and he takes on well it was an
interesting choice to take on g7 but
alvarez is a little bit ahead of the
clock
puts his bishop the king to rookie two
and he's trying to get the epon going at
the right moment
but hey carson knight e3 yeah there's a
93s wow
there should be two comes though at the
end e queen bishop d2
wow and okay i was thinking maybe rook
takes d2
to play with the knight against the rook
but he decides to just go down a piece
which i don't think i agree with because
pre-move is so easy for white here
yeah just throwing a check rookie five
you can just and look at this
trey qc364 just pre-move that and oliver
is it takes that one so he
is maybe a bit faster even though his
car won that time swim before
i don't know i get the feeling that
oliveriza wants that exact scenario
where they're both
scrambling with just two seconds left
because he trusts his mouth speed
100 100 like uh that's why honestly i
was so impressed because
that is ali reza's wheelhouse where he
had hikaru previously
so impressive by hikaru that he was able
to come back from that and beat alireza
at his own game
flagging him and look at this position
this looks great for black you control
the open a file
the e5 pawn is a target the b3 pawn's a
target knight takes b3 is a free pawn
and all the razor's playing really well
right now he sure is bishop to h3 knight
g5 i was about to say kick him right
back where he came from
can't take on f5 because the knight f3
four look at rook a4 the knights are
protecting one another
they're not superfluous here they're
doing a great job the f5 pawn is
actually essential because that gave
black additional flexibility yeah this
is a great game by alareza but he needs
to put it away
he needs to come back in this match this
is a perfect game to start doing that
and look at bishop before tactically
defending knight and c3 if there was a
trade because 92 check ideas
and so king of fate the knights in there
for white
wow it car just walks in the pin and
doesn't mind
it feels like some kind of knight g4
knight f1 rookie m8 but how do you make
that work
yeah i mean f6f1 doesn't threatening
anything he had f6 there just kick the
knight e6
first just don't wait that drop step
somehow with check i was like don't drop
f7 which is why i played e6 and then i
dropped f7 with check
h5 i was gonna say he wants to sink that
knight in and that is a checkmate and if
you take the knight well hang on that's
another checkpoint
wow so it is four to three just like
that a three-game
lead is now down to one hikara probably
feeling some of the pressure here and
ali raza his
form has improved the more games that
are played yeah absolutely i feel like
he's getting used to that
laptop that he's playing on because one
thing when you start streaming robert
you actually do get used to playing on
the monitor and
with that setup every single day so he
might have always played bullet on his
laptop
goes back to it and suddenly he's just a
little you know out of sorts
well getting used to setups is important
especially in chess i mean look at this
right now alireza pushes black back he
gets rid of that bishop one g4 so he can
push his pawn there
and i mean all things consider this
looks like what
you want from the white side because you
all the space
on the king side in the center f5 is an
idea you can play g5 knight f2 knight g4
at some point trying to get your knight
into f6
so i like what alirez is doing here yeah
the knight on e4 though for black is
really nice basically if black can take
his bishop
maybe throw it on c5 i think he'd be
very happy the bishop on g7 is
not where it wants to be wow an f5
creating a weakness in e6 a french-like
idea
that could pay off but i think actually
the e6 pawn is very weak here
yeah and he's just gonna triple on the
the e file however watch that f4 pawn
after bishop takes d4
okay well that bishop sinks into the e5
square oh opening the f file might not
be such a good idea
white gets this outside past one but oh
bishop g5
he runs into this because he missed
queen g6 check i think that was a really
important insertion
and now it's an extra change but that
king on b7 is not safe so
even though black stop material and time
there is some hope here for ali raza
because of that
lack of king safety yeah and rookie
nicely done he keeps the queen
off the seventh and the eighth ring okay
but down goes this pawn queen e5 was the
idea of queenie for a great move by car
queen
check and e5 winning the g4 pawn wow now
the white king looks like it's about to
get checkmated
and look how safe that king is on a6 and
here it goes rook cheats rookie four
going to e1 with check
rookie two and he's just making steady
progress really impressive
and queen b3 there's no check for white
so he gets the mate and
one more game before the break whoo 5'3
hikaru that was a huge game for him to
stop the bleeding he was losing a bunch
of games there now he gets a win two
game lead once more
and this game will be essential because
the two point lead if that becomes three
heading into the break that's bad news
for alareza
yeah i mean you mentioned how important
the last game was i think this one is
critical for the match because you
mentioned it if ali reza is down
three points going into the break that
is a tough lead to overcome he's going
to need to come back the likes of which
we've seen
from you know andrew tang down five to
one and even from alabasa
yesterday to storm back when he
shouldn't even have a chance to against
artemyev
and look at these knights and look at
them clamping on the position
these pawns for white taking control of
the whole board the bishop one b7
is useless right now you would love to
play c5 but guess what there's a knight
on c5 now pawn there
that light squared bishop is no good
sometimes in positions like that
you play the move c5 as black give up an
entire pawn
just to open the diagonal because look
at the future that bishop on c8 it's not
that bright at the moment until
you know you play e5 and things change
but that was a really good decision
about alareza even though he's down upon
right now
he's opening that bishop you've got
bishop five's coming oh that is a
bad time for a car to see e5 and look at
this the attack against the white king
and well i said until things change
things have changed things have
different changes they're
doubling rooks on the second rank here
of rook to d2
oh he takes the a4 pawn okay that still
looks good now wait knight g6
there's a meeting net yeah nature oh no
h7 king agency oh my goodness
everything's mate robert brooke takes
before and then rookie eight
it's made by force yeah and
ali raza he grimaces there that is a
huge
victory for hikaru nakamura who's now up
six to three
and a month we just saw out of the gates
hikaru came with some fine form took a
big lead
alireza swindled his way back a little
bit there and now the lead is ballooned
to three once more
if you're alire's coach what do you tell
him
happy there's a break uh really good
timing for him it was starting to
to really pull away and that's what
hikaru can do i mentioned it time and
time again when you're playing hikaru
that the game should start adding up and
you're like trying to do the math how do
i get down
three games what where did that come
from he he does it in
just a very casual manner but um ali
reza i'm trying to
remember some of the openings that he
had and i actually did like
most of the openings that he got with
the white pieces against hikaru's setup
that sort of
c6 e6 like modern looking uh position
that he car likes to go for
i think ali reza should keep going for
that because his positions have been
good there that
albeit the last time they had the game
he was getting outplayed by hikaru but
i feel like the openings there are
always great definitely something to go
back to
and from hikaru's perspective i was a
game seven uh sorry game
eight rather instead of this last one
here at the one before when the car was
black that was a really great game by
him where he went up the exchange
converted with ease checkmate alarisa it
seems like
hikaru he stopped his problems by losing
two in a row
and then he's back but the break comes
at a good time we're going to take it
we'll be back
shortly with more from this bullet chess
championship presented by sig
semi-final between akara nakamura and
ali raza furuja
all right and we see here the winner of
hikaru nakamura is a fruit match takes
on
andrew tang who's eagerly awaiting his
opponent for the final
amman hikaru has jumped out to a six to
three
lead he's doing extremely well he
started off well
the middle was going only raised his way
then back to hikaru so
you said what must be done for other
razor going forward here it looks like
he needs to play quickly
he's getting these time deficits out of
the opening and i think that's really
coming back to haunt him game after game
yeah because what we know that uh a
strategy
that ali reza is ready to use and
rightfully so he's quite good at it
is flagging and it's it's not just you
know when there's one second left that
he's faster than hikaru i think
he believes that if there's like five
five seconds left
uh that he will be able to flag hikaru
nakamura
he's confident in his mouse speed and
he's playing on the laptop which
we made our jokes about it but honestly
laptop smaller screen
that's usually where you want to play
your bullet chest i know even when i'm
streaming you got that big monitor but
sometimes
uh the you know very very strong bullet
players will actually shrink their board
so that the mouse just simply travels
less distance so
i think he's setting himself up to just
be a very speedy player but
that's why it was just so weird those
first couple games robert he was so slow
we we need to see him like get get off
to a better start as you mentioned
well let's see if we can do it here he
plays d4 once again hit cargo in the
same system
game after game just trying to take over
the light squares and play quickly
and an early h3h4 situation i think that
favors white
yeah and we we usually see like this
bishop f2 eventual queen e1
and just targeting h4 and look at this
where
you could take on e4 and play knight g5
yeah this looks really good for white
the opening the f file is not supposed
to be good for black and
h4 is weak e4 can be captured actually
can take it right now
and white's going up the pawn yeah the
the g5 pawn
is loose so he locked e3 because knight
d5
oh gosh how quickly these things turn
i know look how quickly he caro finds
that move capitalizes on it
still manageable for ali reza's actually
e3 falls that can't be right
no that's the good news for el reserve
taken c3 pawn takes
he can take an f5 at any moment if he
wants it and look at the c5 he needs to
get to the b
file asap like uh he's gonna rook f3 but
hikar smartly play for b6
yeah and he car's got to play c5 right
at some point get that moving
i think so and the h4 pawn is it target
wait a second rook b7 check
okay four first this looks very
dangerous for black
fabric c4 move is really good he's just
gonna pick that off and if he can pick
off the h4 pawn now there's no checkmate
to worry about like the last time yeah
we just saw how that works out
and now f7 is falling once f7 falls then
e6 and g6 are very weak
this should be alarese's game here 100
he's got an h-bond that can run he's
winning every single pawn that hikaru
has and the knight is just dominated by
the bishop
wait there's some kind of no there's no
knight f1 check is the king and slide
out to g2 but you know that
drawing mechanism that sometimes is
placing while you're down a piece now
and
always has plenty of time to convert
this yeah i think hikaru is
probably uh playing on a little bit to
do with the the clock
not not to do with any belief that he
has a chance
no and this is smart because hikaru has
the experience of playing in all the
speed chess championships
he knows that you should play the mascot
he's going to waste his remaining 10
seconds
and that is very smart
yep gameplay we saw uh ali reza's
opponent
you know uh it didn't work out for him
because he wasn't looking at the match
clock that's of course artemia
so kikaru using the match clock for what
it's supposed to be used for running
down uh when you're ahead
for sure in a casual game on stream you
resign that and go to the next game
but in a match like this you have to let
the clock tick we saw what artemia if
you just mentioned that
that was disaster for vladislav so
hikaru nakamura knows better he's going
to waste the time if it helps him
wait a second is there some kind of
knight takes g2 coming that would be
very very exciting to see a move like
that with that bishop on b7 lined up
either way this looks very promising for
black because all your pieces are in
perfect squares but hikaru playing
quickly
trying to find an idea here and there it
is d4
and he goes quickly with that walking
into the pin with queen c3 and queen d2
i feel like he car was kind of flailing
with the queen but it might work out
well speaking of pins the d file pin is
annoying and the d4 pawn is in trouble
so yep you just won the d4 pawn though
actually ali riz is out playing hikaru
maybe he's moving a little too quickly
right right
b2 is hanging here as well but he yeah
sorry
f2 and rook takes g3 were a simultaneous
threat which is probably why he played
bishop d4
and that's just a much nicer way to do
it like he stops at bishop d4 you might
expect bishop b2 and pre-move in that
situation knight c6 bishop e5 where's
that rook going if you go to
okay he just trades the rooks this way
because he figures he's up two pawns
here
and optimize the board yeah i like that
decision really really smart just don't
blunder king f6
like some sort of knight d5 but um yeah
i really really like that choice
okay bishop c7 keep your pawns protect
that knight
i don't know about this because the
h-pawn is the wrong pawn
you want to give yep give those h pawns
because that's the wrong color corner
yeah i i still think this was the right
decision it's much easier to pre-move
with black and i think he was getting
low on time so
i understand why you did that yeah for a
few moves i saw the eval bars you know
on our screen saying that oh it's
should be equal but not in a bullet game
and not with these split pawns like this
and this is going to be a win for
alareza
yeah i actually don't really know why he
car didn't keep playing
that position like just go king d1 and
bishop c6 and
like i don't know i think that if he's
trying to run the match clock i think he
can run it for way longer than he just
did
because i think you need to balance
running the mascot with also your nerves
and if you kept playing and was losing
there's still some stress involved
e6 was just player like there's a queen
hanging on that f5 but
you know there's some stress involved
there by the way this this looks
absolutely terrible for black rook takes
f7 that's winning on the spot
wow bishop g6 and then bishop e8
and bishop g5 yeah after the king goes
to e7 bishop g5 was made so
ali raza storming back here 96 knight f7
yeah he's just storming the castle right
now queen e6 and this should be lights
out i said that these openings were
really really good for ali reza and he's
proving it here
yeah he's up how many pawns right now is
it four no
now two pawns but it looks like more and
wow c3 what a calm move just to win a
piece and a car resigns and it's an
even match right now it was 6'3 at the
break whatever ali raza fuji did let us
know
because i want to know how to storm back
in zakar nakamura it is a tied matchup
and talk about running down the clock
now you might want those 10 seconds that
you ran off the clock earlier back you
might need them to to come back if ali
reza wins the next game
yeah we have eight minutes 20 seconds
remaining and all the reason with the
black pieces is taking a
hikaru-like approach because very solid
you see the b7 c6 f7 e60 are temmie of
like approach too
and just saying i have no real
weaknesses yet hikaru game after game
was up on the clock
and has been honestly punishing alireza
for these setups
it's true c5 so probably see i was going
to say the c5 pawn taken but he also
gives up the bishop i'm not sure about
that decision
yeah i think you wanted to keep the
bishop here that's a good call the f5
pawn is very strong
it's protected you see this little f7 e6
f5 configuration
now the c file's open so that should
give black some chances here
but a5 is a big problem yeah and he's
looking to gang up on this pawn bishop
d4 and brook
check is important and the brook is
trapped on b4
well we talk about resigning the same
time look all the written results say
wow you had a nice tactical sequence
that one's for you
still seven half minutes remaining in
this match oh and this looks like a good
opening for white here
uh to start off that normally when you
play the queen's gamut and play
knight f6 and have to take with the
knight early on that's a nice way to get
a bad position early on in bullet
yeah it sort of looks like it's
transitioned into a gruntfeld
but probably one that white is not
unhappy about
okay this looks very awkward for black
but i guess the bishop 6 for now is okay
bishop e2 is going to break the pin and
here if there's like bishop d4
knight takes b2 i wonder how that works
out and so he gets bishop c1 very calm
move
and this is a strange position you're
going to see this every day where the
knight
on c4 very active causing white some
problems with the bishop f6
is very sturdy there protected by the
pawn and the d4 squares
can be blacks for the taking well it can
be and is at the moment
uh there's no fork on c2 so how about a
fork on f5
wow i think you can play bishop e3
because we've taken e4 queen e4 and this
bishop e6 mating ideas
incredible yeah taking the knight bishop
queen b3's mate
or it's close to mate on the diagonal
it's a good move we'll put it that way
that's a damn good move wow this is very
complicated an e6 played
knight g5 yeah that looks good now just
bishop b2 just move the bishop back all
right f3
this looks good too rook c1 to c7 knight
takes e6
does not a6 works oh he's lost he moved
back but a7 is hanging you take that
pawn and then b7 falls next right
queen h how did he see that it looked
like you're losing a piece and cuisine
forced the queen trade
and now that rook on the seventh rank
looks really good for white
take that comes tonight here comes the
knight knight e5
wow and knight g4 back okay but hikaru
fighting off here
he really is it's all about the time
that bishop d5 coming soon
careful of the clock here yeah i think
oh that hangs a piece alaris
was moving really quickly there and rook
there's got to be some kind of mate
somewhere alireza i think did the right
thing he invested time
and now he's starting to pre-move once
he's got the keys and now it's easy you
up a piece and that means the black king
has a harder time finding squares
and it looks like hikaru just throws in
the towel doesn't want to compete with
him
in the time scribble it is seven all
still five plus minutes remaining
i'm on the first match today it felt
like that match went by very quickly
this feels like it's going slowly still
five minutes left we've had so much
excitement yeah and i
i actually um i disagree with hikaru
there
not playing on uh i understand that you
know the superstar young ali reza is so
fast he's the favorite in the time
scramble but hey you got to put your
skills to the test he car already showed
earlier on
that he can flag alireza he you know
he's a fast player i'd like to see him
play those on
yeah i agree with you there i think
knight d4 now is kind of forced for
fergus rook is in danger of getting
trapped in f5
so this trade is very strange you'll see
this very often with his pawn structure
two sets of double pawns
you know he's crashing through on the
queen side that's his goal yeah and that
g5 move forcing the bishop back to d8 is
quite strong here
uh you do have to watch out for the f4
pawn though and d5 coming such a strong
move
and he wants to go bishop c7 uh we
should be six wow
i was like wait the rook's still hanging
there and he just plays like this and
takes him too far because the brook's
hanging
stuff that was absolutely sick that
whole sequence
that was unreal that he saw all that
he's protecting g7 so no checkmates for
white and now the pawn structure
is slightly better for black because of
this isolated f5 pawn good move by a car
that rook g6
oh trade and trade everything uh i'm not
sure this works for hikaru
king f6 and you play h5 kg5 th5
okay he's pushing five and eight maybe
h5 there was actually a really cool move
but this is queen b6 check and they're
no stalemates because of the president
a3 pawn
wow wow that game was insane honestly
masterpiece from farouz it
didn't look like much because they're
very small tactical subtleties but
just to be able to come out of that
position with c6 small things
rook takes g5 and then taking the end
game confidently and from
6-3 down to 8-7 up ali raza is on a tear
right now he gets the white pieces in
this game
he's going for the bishop pair he could
take on g6 now he has both bishops
against two knights but the the position
is close so kind of
easy for the knights to maneuver around
and i'm not sure about this decision to
trade on d4 i think that hurts black's
king
yeah i'm not sure about that it's
important that white got to play bishop
takes d5 though the fact that black
doesn't get to anchor a knight there
really hurts his chances and macca is
just worse in this end game
yeah bishop c3 trading rooks the h3
point could be captured with background
checkmates
so look at all there is ago he's just
trading down oh
that can go with a check yeah didn't
love
um and extra pawn i think we love it
once more
yeah i was gonna say i didn't love the
way he somehow just lost the clean pawn
there
but i love the way he won a clean pun
there so and king c5 can be
six okay but these positions
in classical chess oh well not even
classical just now
rook b3 is
yeah you just bring the king around e6
and i would say if it's not enough it
should be an effing bullet well look at
the clock though
his car is way ahead on time
g5 oh no he could not allow that moving
he resigns because he understands
there's just over two minutes left and
it's a two-game lead for alareza for
russia
so even if this goes the distance it car
might just have enough time to start one
more game
this game is uh well this game is for
the finals robert put it that way
um i think that hikaru is probably
decently happy with his opening
but he needs to get that free match in
really quick
yeah if i'm all there is i'm never
resigning i'm going yeah if i'm losing
this game i am playing until i have
negative time remaining because
you want that match clock to run out a
car playing very quickly here with the
white pieces i'm not even sure i like
white's
position practically speaking now i do
after that i love it yeah look at those
pawns going oh okay i changed my mind
real quick look at that pawn chain the
bishop on g2 unopposed and the long
diagonal
looking very good for a car right now
yeah and he keeps the rook on the board
rook
f1 is there some night discovery not
really there's no good movement oh
i don't know about that letting the pawn
chain look at the light squares
oh my goodness yeah but maybe he has a
blockade
because when you have this locked up
structure like this
how are you going to break through you
need a knight for white to get to d5 or
something like that
right and he's just looking to trade
pieces go a5 stay all on the dark
squares and say hey you can't beat me
i don't buy it but um it's the right
strategy i mean it might be frustrating
to play against
and look at this your g5 is going to be
played h takes h
oh throws in g6 but now it's totally
locked up yeah i don't know about that
you need to maybe to play g takes h6 i
think hikar will regret that
he might still he might still win this
game but i think
[Music]
that was sick oh bishop takes g7 as well
that was so sick oh my gosh we we're
just talking the positions locked up but
he saw the queen joint and the tactics
for the past pawns
and speaking of past pawns there are
multiple it is a
win in a second here don't just don't
move alareza
it doesn't matter there's gonna be one
more game so you can resign it doesn't
matter it's the same thing
and we have one last game that was
exceptional by hikar enough bishop takes
h6
bishop g7 pre-moved robert because he
knew that e7 was a threat as well as g7
totally sick but now we're in the most
important game of the entire match and
must win game three kara nakamura this
decides who goes to the final
and here i think white should be queen
of three good move keep the center as
close as possible because you don't want
to see that bishop hit the e4 pawn
the b4 pawn was captured and look at
that move very quickly by
car knight c5 trying to go after the e4
pawn white is up one but the bishops
look good for black
yeah and if hicara wins this we will
have that you know coveted tie break
that we've seen before
but if ali reza draws the game or wins
it that's enough to send him through
and look at this decision by others but
b5 if bishop ever took on d4
you could just trade off and then you
win the b5 but that's not going to give
you the most winning chances
for a car and right speaking of winning
chances where are they yeah ali reza
got a great position now after h4
however sometimes these solid positions
when you try to break through and go for
mate they don't work
oh there might be a rook c5 tactic there
to hit the d5 but either way
what is black going to do here there's
some kind of queen c4 oh my gosh
just taking my king e2 yeah i think this
is a good end game for white but
bishop b4 big threat yes hikaru can't
repeat
no he can't repeat just look at this can
you two rook c7 check
throw in the checks rupee seven look at
the time though hikaru is in a position
where he can break a three's a blunder
because rick takes e7 mm-hmm
so rugby rook b7 how do you shoot e7
oh missionary seven was a possibility i
don't know if it's good though and the
car is doing his best his king is around
14 seconds for all rizza so check
when's the 50 move roll you've thrown a
pawn move at some point yeah he will
play g4 i think at some point
and there it is there it is he throws it
in he's up 10 more than 10 seconds
this is he should be four oh oh yeah
should be four at that moment and now
and now he plays it
oh but look at that move throwing in the
check just to gain some time this is
actually
expert bullet oh oh the rocks
already had the match he had the tie but
he lost his rookies it was all of his
pawns he just has to take the pawn
that's it that's the match that's it
hikaru you can't pre-move there oh
he had that game and ali raised the
farouza for the second
day in a row he wins because of this
sneaky little
take something pre-move winning the game
and that is that ali rizzo farouz smiles
he works his way to the finals of the
bullet chess championship and he will
face
andrew tang that wasn't even the final
match i feel like that was the final and
oh my goodness i can't believe it
two ali reza's credit that was not a
dirty move he played rook c2
protected by his king he simply wanted
to trade so that wasn't that wasn't
like any of the other moves we've seen
from ali reza but
it worked out just the same hikaru
should not be pre-moving there why
he had such a time lead robert he just
needed to put his rook
safe and then pre-move the king and
leaving his rook exposed there my
goodness he gets punished for it we will
not
see hikaru nakamura in the finals and
ali reza in dramatic fashion
reminds us that semifinals could be
exciting too robert
both of these matches were extremely
excited down to the wire
and ali raza was down three points
against ikaru nakamura and yet he makes
his way to the finals
ali raisa i think got in a car's head a
bit some of those time scrambles were
going already's way so
car said i need a pre-move because even
though he may have five seconds
remaining
that's enough time for alireza to play
and that rook
was left hanging for a couple moves
there because alvarez started pre-moving
his king away
and the rook stayed in each other's path
that was a
amazing save by ali reza there he moves
on to face andrew tang and amman
before we go to break what do you make
of this finale
andrew tang versus already frugia uh
two people that are uh you know on top
of their game right now i can't wait to
see the time scrambles between them
because they are both capable of some of
the the most insane
moves uh pre-moves dirty moves at the
right time
calculating pre-moves that we've ever
seen from any player in this competition
the two most deserving players are
definitely in the final and they're both
young talented super speedy guys who
back it up with tactics and good chess
roberts so
i can't wait to get back in let's save
the hot takes for after the break
[Music]
you